that we're joined now by the foreign
secretary liz truss minister lovely to
have you good morning this morning good
morning
let us start then with rwanda as things
stand at the moment and of course there
was a significant legal victory at the
high court and the court of appeal
yesterday for the government how many
people are we expecting to send to
rwanda later today well we are expecting
to send the flight later today
i can't say exactly how many people will
be on the flight but the really
important thing is that we establish the
principle and we start to break the
model the business model of these
appalling people traffickers who are
trading in misery that is why we're
doing this policy and that's why it's
important that we get the flight out
today
you you might not be able to put a
specific number on it but it is it is
pretty clear that the number who will be
on that flight if anyone is on that
flight will be significantly less than
that than you had intended that's fair
to say isn't it
the important thing is that we get the
flight out we establish the principle
and we start demonstrating to people
that this business model of trafficking
people into the united kingdom risking
their lives in the english channel
simply doesn't work and it's important
we get the flight out we don't know
exactly how many people will be on that
flight but they will go on future
flights and i understand completely your
desire to avoid putting a figure on when
things may well be fluid throughout the
day but is it possible that this plane
will take off with no one on it
there will be people on the flight and
if they're not on this flight they will
be on the next flight because we are
determined to break the model of the
appalling people traffickers and sort
this issue out which has caused untold
misery including people dying in the
english channel completely and there
would be people watching this that that
understand that but there will also be
people who are concerned about the the
costs of sending people to rwanda can we
put a figure on how much today's flight
will be costing
i can't put a figure on that but what we
have to look at is the cost of
illegal immigration the cost to the
united kingdom the cost of the
individuals and their families who are
suffering from the actions of these
people traffickers that's the
that's the issue
that we are seeking to deal with
by
putting in place this route to rwanda
and it's very important we get that
route going we show that people
trafficking doesn't work and we're able
to reduce the costs
over time of illegal immigration into
the united kingdom can completely get
that point but there are reports this
morning that suggests because of the the
the the legal action in which you
weren't successful with the at the high
court there could be as few as seven
people on that flight today
is that accurate
well as i say i don't
i don't have a figure the important
point is the principle
that we are establishing the
practicalities are always will be
going to rwanda uh if they're not on
this flight they will be on the next
flight we want to break the model of the
people trafficking yeah you've said that
we want to stop these costs both in
monetary costs but also in human misery
that these illegal immigration routes
are causing so you think it's value for
money no matter what it costs it is
value for money
what is the legal situation then of
people who are refused asylum in this
country popped on a plane sent to rwanda
and granted asylum there
would they be able to re-enter the
united kingdom
they will be permanently located in
rwanda and that is the agreement that we
have with the rwandan government i think
it's important to note that this is a
agreement with rwanda also about helping
rwanda develop their economy helping
people live locally in rwanda but if
they're successful in their asylum claim
in rwanda it does suggest that we might
have got it wrong at this end
but
the important thing is that we are
establishing the principle
that people
are being relocated to rwanda and
settled in rwanda other people would say
that it is equally as important that as
a you know as a forward-thinking nation
we act with moral integrity and all of
this i just want to you will have seen
you'll have seen the comments of the
church of england but for you for
viewers who have not i just need to show
them this the church of england has
written a letter to say that this this
in essence shames britain can we bring
that up please alan i think we should
have it for the screen yeah
um whether or not the first deportation
flight leaves britain today for rwanda
this policy should shame us as a nation
this is the church of england saying
this it continues
i hope yeah the shame is our own because
our christian heritage should inspire us
to treat asylum seekers with compassion
fairness and justice as we have for
centuries this immoral policy shames
britain again the church of england
which as far as i'm aware is not some
den of new marxism is accusing this
government of immorality
i don't agree with that the
people who are immoral in this case are
the people traffickers trading on human
misery and that is denying that the
people traffickers are immoral they're
just simply saying that
those people neil need to suggest an
alternative policy that will work to
deal with these illegal people
trafficking explain the logic of that to
me that someone else has to come up with
a better idea than yours for your idea
to be to be ruled out as a immoral
what i'm saying is our policy
is completely legal
it's completely moral we are housing
people in a safe country in rwanda what
i'm saying to the critics of the policy
who don't have an alternative about how
we deal with this illegal migration is
they don't have an alternative they're
criticizing
our policy which is effective and does
work when a majority a significant
majority of those passing over the
channel are successful in their asylum
claims what on earth is the rationale
for this
the rationale is that we have a
migration partnership with rwanda it's
about helping develop rwanda it's about
stopping these illegal routes and people
acting in a way that endangers human
life that is the logic of the policy
let's turn our attention to northern
ireland and of course the protocol big
big discussion ongoing you were hitting
the phone yesterday morning sibcovich
and of course across across the irish
sea as well just explain if you can in
simple terms to our viewers exactly what
is wrong with the northern ireland
protocol that your government negotiated
signed ratified
what has happened is the northern
ireland protocol and the impact of it
has undermined the belfast good friday
agreement so we're seeing people in
northern ireland not able to access the
same goods as people in great britain
we're seeing customs costs
of trading goods across the irish sea
we're seeing people not able to benefit
from the same tax breaks as people in gb
so when the chancellor at the spring
statement gave a vat cut on solar panels
that wasn't available in northern
ireland so people in northern ireland
particularly in the unionist community
are feeling that they are less connected
to great britain and that they are not
benefiting from being part of the united
kingdom and that is a problem that we
need to deal with it has been going on
now for 18 months we've had 18 months of
negotiations we haven't got anywhere the
eu have said that they're unwilling to
change the protocol therefore we have to
act to make sure we restore
the primacy of the belfast good friday
agreement this this is all wined in the
kind of the legal paper that you
published yesterday you set out
your use of the doctrine of necessity uh
to justify in essence going back on your
international your international
agreement with uh with the european
union just explain exactly where the
grave and immediate peril that you are
required to demonstrate to use the
doctrine
where that grave and immediate peril
exists to my mind i'm not sure that you
know having to fill in forms to send
sausages to belfast counts as grave and
immediate peril
i think we all remember
how hard one peace and political
stability was in northern ireland and
the importance of the belfast good
friday agreement in establishing
both the successful north-south
relationships north-south trade and
north-south communities but also the
east-west relationships
suggest that there are people who know a
lot more about the troubles than you and
i and their technique would if they
could be sitting in storming at the
moment a majority of mlas disagree with
the action that you're taking they don't
see grave in the media pedal in front of
them i'm not sure invoking the troubles
right now is a is helping your argument
what the belfast good friday agreement
on is based on is the principle
of parity of esteem
of both communities in northern ireland
and you did mention the mlas those
weren't mlas from the unionist community
and the point is we need the consent
of both communities in northern ireland
we need both communities to be treated
fairly and equally and that's what we're
doing
through our northern ireland protocol
legislation i will be clear neil that we
would rather have a negotiated agreement
with the eu and this is what i said to
the eu yesterday
what we need is changes to the protocol
that are causing real problems in
northern ireland
raising costs but also making people
feel like they're not part of you not
negotiated with the european union
formally since february then
i have been in talks with the european
union in february in march we've had 18
months of talks
the
together
the fundamental point
is that the eu won't change the text of
the protocol and it's the text of the
protocol that's causing problems those
are again completely exciting so it's
difficult to negotiate with somebody who
won't change
the thing that you want to negotiate
with that's consequent what consequences
in northern ireland that you are
complaining about right now were not
predicted before we ratified this
well there have been unintended
consequences and what we've seen
over time neil is things gradually
getting worse in northern ireland
what i cannot allow the protocol and the
declarations you were going to sign up
to would involve the czechs that you now
complain about that would be highly
destructive to the northern ireland
economy that you're now complaining
about all the problems that you now
identify with the northern protocol were
obvious to people on both sides of the
rbc before you signed it so this grave
and immediate peril that you need to
have to invoke the doctrine it's just
not there you were being warned about it
three years ago
what we have seen is the situation
gradually getting worse we haven't seen
the executive in northern ireland
established since february we've seen
the trading situation get worse
diversion towards north-south away from
east west and this is why we need to act
this is why we cannot allow the
situation to drift and we cannot allow
the belfast good friday agreement to be
further undermined that's why the
government's determined to act and we're
doing so in a reasonable way we're not
changing the european union we're not
changing i would say no to that we're
not changing the whole protocol neil
we're changing the bits but the ideas
that are causing a rail it's just it's
beyond the pale i mean in your command
paper of the middle of last year lord
frost was talking actively about
triggering article 16. indeed let's talk
about that why are we unilaterally
changing our position on the protocol
rather than using the mechanism
contained within it for precisely
moments like this
well the issue with article 16 and
triggering article 16
is all it would do
is put the situation back to what it is
now because we haven't fully implemented
the protocol we've only implemented part
of the protocol we have a standstill
arrangement at the moment and in order
to fix the problems
which are generating the issues in
northern ireland the customs across the
irish sea the requirement for customs
codes the tax differences for the people
of northern ireland from the people of
great britain we need to deal with the
protocol itself so article 16 and
triggering it simply wouldn't have
delivered the solution we need to fix
the problems in northern ireland and
this is what i'm saying to the eu
i want to negotiate with the eu but they
have to be willing to change the text of
the protocol again again you you suggest
that things are getting worse but all of
the problems that have been identified
right now in northern ireland were
identified prior to to the ratification
of of the northern ireland protocol i
mean it isn't the simple truth that you
all knew it was a bad deal when you
signed up to it but you needed to get
brexit done you got brexit done
and you intended as you are currently
doing wriggling out of it in the way
that you are
we are addressing very very serious
issues in northern ireland that have
emerged over the past two years
honestly
which they have caused problems of
political instability as we can see from
the fact the executive hasn't formed
they've caused economic and trade
problems in north island just performing
the solution the average the uk economy
on average the solution we're putting
forward doesn't make the eu any worse
off
it protects the eu single market
at the same time as fixing these
problems in northern ireland so we are
working on a practical solution
that works for everybody yes we want to
persuade the eu to negotiate with us to
change the protocol to achieve that but
we cannot allow this situation in
northern ireland to drift that is where
we are now which is what i'm focused on
having responsibility for the protocol i
completely understand and whilst we have
your minister and it is it is away from
your brief and i understand this but it
is the anniversary of the grenfell tower
fire 72 people
lost their lives
this government promised that people
would no longer live in unsafe buildings
like that they also promised that people
would not have to put their hands in
their pockets to rectify the cladding
neither of those things have happened
and as of this morning there will be
people waking up to this conversation
living in unsafe buildings
the likes of grenfell tower what is this
government going to do about it
i mean i think we all have huge sympathy
with the people caught in that appalling
tragedy and it was it was horrific i
think we all remember
how horrific it was
we have been able to
re-house i think 98 percent of people
who were living in grenfell i think
everybody's off been offered
alternative accommodation
we are supporting those particularly
those who live in
buildings of more than 11 stories to
make sure that they have 11 meters sorry
to make sure that they are not having to
put their hands in the pockets to pay
for cladding and i know
that my colleague the housing secretary
is doing work with the building industry
to tackle uh these these very very
serious issues of fire safety of of
building regulation but i think we just
all remember how utterly appalling
that tragedy was
we certainly do and let's trust thank
you so much for joining us really
appreciate the time thank you